in Sipplingen am Bodensee soll im Jahr
2015 aus dem lehrstehenden Hotel Adler
eine Flüchtlingsunterkunft werden das
Landratsamt mietet dafür das Gebäude in
der Ortsmitte an für 9 Jahre erst nach
Unterzeichnung des Mietvertrags fällt
auf das Gebäude ist ein Sanierungsfall
das Hotel wird nie als Unterkunft
genutzt der Kreis zahlt dennoch
jahrelang Miete und 800.000 Euro
oh man muss sich doch vergewissern wenn
wir vorne so viel Geld ausgibt für eine
Objekt ob das überhaupt tauglich ist für
sowas für mich eigentlich unerklärlich
weil das Landratsamt ist einfach in
meine Augen einfach nur blind angemietet
man müsste doch vorher fragen was macht
man draußen
2015 mietet das Landratsamt das Gebäude
an bei genauerem Hinsehen und rechnen
wird klar 530000 Euro wären für eine
Sanierung fällig insbesondere die
Brandschutzmaßnahmen sind in dem alten
und verwinkelten Gebäude schwierig alles
zu aufwendig zu teuer das Landratsamt
entscheidet das gerade erst angemietete
Gebäude gar nicht zu nutzen
seitdem steht das Haus leer wie teuer
das mietdebakel ist soll die
Öffentlichkeit aber nicht erfahren
Medienanfragen zu den Kosten beantwortet
der Kreis nicht wir waren von Anfang an
der Auffassung speziell in diesem Fall
hat die Öffentlichkeit sehr wohl ein
Recht darauf zu erfahren
was hier gelaufen ist und wie ihre wie
wie wie Steuergelder verwendet werden
der Südkurier verlangt Auskunft verklagt
den Bodenseekreis und gewinnt das
Landratsamt muss die Zahlen rausrücken
und die sind übel jeden Monat zahlt die
öffentliche Hand 6400 € plus Nebenkosten
und das unglaubliche 9 Jahre lang beim
Kreis verteidigt man die nutzlose
Anmietung wehrt sich gegen den Vorwurf
einer Fehlplanung
krisen können nicht geplant werden und
deshalb kann es auch keine Fehlplanung
geben wir haben damals eine Entscheidung
getroffen in einer Notsituation und
diese Entscheidung war wie gehen dieses
Risiko ein ein langfristigen Mietvertrag
einzugehen ohne ein allgemeines
Rücktrittsrecht dieser Vertrag ohne
Rücktrittsrecht kommt die Steuerzahler
teuer zu stehen aber das ist natürlich
schon Riese Beträge die da
ausgegeben sind so einfach ich hoffe
dass die Verantwortlichen die da
irgendwas damit zu tun haben dass das da
irgendjemand zur Verantwortung gezogen
wird der Vertrag ist inzwischen
aufgelöst die Miete für die neuen Jahre
musste der Landkreis allerdings voll
bezahlen und das Hotel Adler steht
weiterhin leer und liegt im
Dornröschenschlaf